Je regarde chacun de vous et je vois les
marques de cette longue et terrible guerre. Si
nous mourons
ce soir, l'humanité meurt avec
nous, la machine a envoyé un Terminator à
l'époque d'avant la guerre pour tuer ma
mère Sarah Conor, laissez-moi sauver
son
monde.  Je ne sais pas quoi faire le moment où il
retournera devrait avoir peur et être faible,
prends soin d'elle. F
Kyle, viens avec moi si tu veux
vivre, tout ne va pas. John m'a envoyé ici pour
te sauver du Terminator qui a été
renvoyé pour me tuer mais  nous avons déjà pris
soin de lui
nous je t'attendais
Tout a
changé nous pouvons empêcher le Jour du Jugement
[Musique] d'
arriver où est-
il je reviendrai
quoi